un hito vergonzoso miles de niños y
niñas han perdido la vida en los seis
años que lleva el conflicto en yemen
tenemos diez mil niños que han sido
asesinados o mutilados desde que
comenzaron los combates en marzo de 2015
este es el equivalente a cuatro niños
cada día por supuesto esos son los
números que las naciones unidas pueden
verificar muchas más muertes y lesiones
de niños no se informan excepto por
supuesto a los miembros de la familia
según cifras de unicef cuatro de cada
cinco niños necesitan asistencia
humanitaria es decir 11 millones 400 mil
de ellos sufren desnutrición aguda
severa y más de 2 millones no van a la
escuela ya que unos 170.000 maestros no
han recibido un salario regular y además
de esto 17 millones de niños son
desplazados por la violencia ese número
por supuesto está aumentando
particularmente en la ciudad de maris
donde estamos viendo cada vez más
familias huyendo de sus hogares en los
últimos días el conflicto en yemen tiene
origen en la primavera árabe de 2011 las
protestas le arrebataron el poder a ali
abdullah saleh quien lo dejó en manos de
él presidente a rabo mansur hadi pero
los yemeníes desilusionados apoyaron un
golpe de estado en su contra en 2014
desde entonces simpatizantes de hadi y
rebeldes útiles del movimiento ánsar alá
se disputan el poder en 2015 la
operación tormenta liderada por arabia
saudita y el lado del mandatario
derrocado inició una serie de bombardeos
aéreos y terrestres desde entonces el
conflicto prolongado ha dejado el país
en una hambruna severa la devastación
económica la precariedad de los
servicios básicos y un estancamiento por
parte de ambos bandos para poner fin a
más de seis años de guerra ha hecho de
esta crisis humanitaria la peor del
mundo